my last question for you is uh today the
company is somewhere 600 650 million
dollar market cap uh the billion dollar
uh numbers out there I've seen you tweet
about building a billion dollar strip
club Empire the whole thing
um what is the importance of that number
and and is there you know something that
you think kind of that billion dollar
Mark unlocks other than just the fact
that you can say that you did it
[Music]
you know I think I think it's going to
add a validation to our company uh I
think some people still look at us as a
strip club company uh oh they're just in
a strip club business oh they're just
you know they're just strip club guys or
they're just strippers I think with a
billion dollar market cap Corporate
America has to go
wow and pay attention
all right guys bang bang I've got Eric
here with me Eric I thought a great
place of stories you guys own a ton of
nightlife restaurants and strip clubs
what exactly is the business model for
these strip clubs is it just ticket
sales and then some sort of fee uh that
you're taking from uh uh all the tips
and kind of the girls earnings or what
exactly is the the business model uh for
these nightlife establishments well the
business models obviously sell uh
alcoholic beverages and and food
merchandise uh the VIP room rentals uh
you know of course you know up sales of
uh you know premium premium Liquors uh
tobacco products I mean we we sell uh
basically everything we can't cover
charges uh there's lots of lots of ways
to make money uh in our in our industry
is there anything that would stand out
for people who aren't familiar with the
business in terms of something that's
much more high margin than they would
think or is it really just alcohol sales
and kind of the things you would assume
are the high margin items I mean
typically we're 40 40 some percent
alcohol sales uh
excuse me 40 some percent service
revenues which are
You Know cover charges VIP room rentals
uh uh dance star commissions stuff like
that uh
and then uh the rest is uh basically
food and merchandise which is typically
eight to twelve percent
got it and then how do you think about
Marketing in today's day and age right
you have these uh kind of um uh
establishments that a lot of folks would
say Obviously of the American economy is
going to continue to use all sorts of
different vices Etc but at the same time
we have these new tools where you can
use social media you can use uh uh you
know email newsletters all that type of
stuff how do you guys think about you
know kind of old industries that
obviously are still as prevalent today
as they ever have been but there's new
uh marketing channels to go ahead and
Leverage I mean we most of our marketing
is social media now whether it's
Google's keyword searches whether it's
uh you know Tick Tock videos whether
it's you know my my personal Twitter
account actually you know with my Rick
CEO Twitter account is is uh big Pharma
marketing I'll I'll post that hey I'm
going to be at the fight tonight it's
Carl it's in Miami uh anybody want to
come have a drink with me and you know
when I first started doing that a year
ago I'd get four or five people show up
now I mean you know sometimes we get 20
plus people show up uh hang out uh you
know we drink we watch fights we hang
out with the girls uh have a good time
so uh it's uh you know all these methods
are are have been fantastic for us
Instagram I know a lot of the
entertainers and weight staff uh you
know have big Instagram accounts and big
Instagram following uh the feature
entertainers uh we're starting to uh
Embrace more of these feature
entertainers because they have you know
three million five million eight million
plus followers uh you know following
their accounts following them uh you
know around the country they do clubs
all over the country and when they come
into a certain Market their followers in
that market and sometimes people travel
to see them uh it's it's actually been
really amazing to see uh the the scope
and level that these entertainers uh as
far as followings have
yeah what's fascinating to me is just
looking at this from a pure business
perspective is there's a number of
different things you all have to deal
with or have to kind of navigate that I
think other businesses are going to have
to navigate two five ten years from now
and so one of these you're hitting on
right now which is that the folks who
are coming into uh these night uh clubs
they are employees they may be
contractors but they actually may have
bigger megaphones than you all have as
an individual business or establishment
and so how can you leverage it and then
also like what are the things that you
wish you could do but because you don't
own the channel you can't actually use
it to promote the uh the establishment
I mean they absolutely have a bigger
megaphone than we do uh you know one of
the I think one of the challenges uh in
the future is making sure that your
influencers are happy that work in your
business because they're influencing a
lot of your business right uh if they're
unhappy they're gonna influence it that
way if they're very happy they're going
to influence you know in a positive
light uh and so these these these
influencers uh are growing uh the amount
of influence they have is growing
especially in the demographic 35 and
under uh traditional radio doesn't work
anymore for for for very many
demographics maybe maybe some of the
Hispanic market uh you know radio is
still good for Spanish-speaking clients
uh but uh other than that I mean it's
all on demand it's all streaming it's
it's all immediate uh and if you don't
have ties into
that you you know I guess that uh that
Marketplace how are you going to draw
those customers into your business uh I
I think we're seeing it uh everywhere
and I think you've run risk right
because now you've got to be careful
politically you've got to be careful you
know socially uh and you got to be
careful who you who you back and who you
use to influence your customer base
because if they influence on it you know
uh the wrong way you know you're gonna
have uh negative effects from that so
it's a much more complicated landscape
uh than we've ever faced in the past
where you just caught up the newspaper
and put an ad in the sports section
right uh those days those days are gone
yeah one of the things that um you know
as I was uh kind of thinking about this
conversation is you have the blessing
and the curse you've been doing this a
long time right 20 20 plus years as uh
yeah yeah yes you've been doing the in
the industry for 30 years a public
company 28 is a public company and uh
about 36 37 years total in the industry
yeah so if you think about that like you
have a bunch of institutional knowledge
you've got a bunch of stuff over the
years that you've learned and kind of
perfected and become an expert at the
same time technology Shifting the market
shifts you know that there's uh
different political climates Etc how do
you stay kind of uh on top of the new
stuff while also understanding what to
take from the experience and the
expertise built up over decades to
continue to build out a great business
I say the the best part is our our staff
uh you know the majority of our
employees uh majority of our
entertainers are 18 to 30 years old uh
and and you know if if they've been in
the industry past that they're typically
moving into management or moving into
you know other positions in the company
uh but we still have the majority 80
probably of our of our our staff is
under the age of 35 for sure probably
under the age of 30. uh so we're very in
tune and we listen and we talk and uh
you know we have to take guidance uh
from from these new generations on how
things are working for them how their
peers are are viewing not just our
industry but just you know how they're
going to spend their money where they're
going to spend their money and why uh
you see the major shift from uh you know
material possessions to experiences uh
and I think that using social media and
using our current staff and and
entertainers to get that message out
that we are an experience to be had not
a product to you know to take home so to
speak uh is is doing wonders for our for
our business overall
now one of the aspects of the business
that you seem very concerned with very
obsessed with is free cash flow and
obviously given kind of the rise of of
tech companies over the last decade or
so uh it's been growth at all costs but
growth really of equity value how can I
appreciate the capital but not
necessarily Drive free cash flow talk a
little bit about what you are doing
inside the business to continue to
optimize for that free cash flow
sure well you know prior to 2015 we were
operating like a tech company growth at
all costs let's buy this let's say you
know yeah it's not making as much money
but we'll grow our Revenue we'll grow
our Revenue uh and our free cash flow
especially on a per share basis uh what
was was stale for about three years that
stuck around 14 to 15 million dollars
in 2015 we developed our Capital
location strategy and said look it's not
just
what
we do on a Top Line how do we get that
to flow down we want about a 20 free
cash flow margin at the bottom line so
if we do a dollar I know we need to get
20 cents uh and free cash flow from that
from that sales uh and so we started
really reevaluating everything it
started with assets uh and I'm you know
invested Capital uh we sold off a bunch
of clubs we make you know weren't making
the money we changed we reformatted and
we really started focusing on free cash
flow we locked down our Equity we paid
off all convertible debts we stopped
warrants we stopped you know stock
options uh anything that would dilute
our capital structure uh we went from uh
total outstandings we started buying
back stock as our you know for a free
cash flow yield was over 10 percent so
we went from 10.8 million fully diluted
shares down to 9.4 million that we were
at today
uh and and we're you know when the
stocks below a certain threshold we
continue to buy back stock uh if that's
what we think is uh you know the best
use of the capital
uh we've been in stock by we bought some
stock back in the last quarter we're
going to be buying stock in this quarter
uh you know with our stock at uh what 65
66 dollars a share now so uh we will
continue to to follow that Capital
location strategy but we what was really
I guess transforming for me was at first
it was just the assets then we started
looking at the human capital right we're
paying a person x what are they doing to
bring in future revenues right uh and
that really changed what I call the
entitlement uh culture at our company or
any company really right you oh I've
been here for 25 years I've done all
these great things for the company and
I'm entitled going forward to continue
uh you know collecting that money
forever uh
and which is fine to it to a point but
at some point you're bringing negative
Roi and so we have to figure out you
know what you're gonna do to bring
forward and I think you know I asked
myself that question all the time what
am I doing if I'm going to get this much
pay yes I did all these great things for
the company I've been paid for doing
those great things for the company and
if I want to continue to get that pay I
have to continue to do great things for
the company uh and is that really move
through our culture in 2016 2017 uh
you're really kind of saw as we right
before covet hit we were in our stride
right we were now sprinting down the
down the runway so to speak and uh
covet hit we had to reevaluate we had
really taught us the next lesson of how
much fat can we cut how much fat do we
really have how many things were we
doing how many process do we have in
place how can we lower costs uh the
processes were we renegotiating every
single aspect of every dollar we spent
and during code we had to do all those
things and so now every year we sat down
and we go through and we question every
dollar we spend uh especially if we're
you know getting the point where our
free cash flow margin is not 20 we want
to keep that free cash flow margin flow
through it about 20 30 even at 20 free
cash flow and so that's our that's our
internal goals
talk about the uh stock buy box one of
the things that over the last couple of
years has obviously become much better
known is some of the best performing
stocks some of the best performing CEOs
uh they did a fantastic job on the
capital allocation front they bought
back stock uh when it was cheap and it
was able to kind of engineer a financial
return for investors that was very very
attractive and so being able to pull
down your shares from just under 11
million to you know kind of just under
nine and a half million now is there a
number that you're trying to get to
eventually is there such a thing as
having too few shares out in the market
like how do you think about you know
taking it to the extreme on the stock
BuyBacks well if you have too many
shares you just split right I mean I can
make more shares tomorrow just split the
stock price stock price Cuts in half
there's twice as many shares outstanding
when we buy back we're buying back at a
lower price uh but you know we can keep
we can keep the count up as high as we
want it's not to me it's not about the
count it's about how much free cash flow
per share are we generating uh and so we
take our pre-cash Flow versus our you
know our number of shares and we you
know you end up with a with the free
cash flow field of of you know it's over
10 percent we tend to buy back stock
more uh if it's under 10 we tend to uh
you know make other Acquisitions uh when
it gets down to six and eight percent
we'll use it in we'll use it in
transactions like the last transaction
we did in March were you know we issued
shares at 80 per share you know uh 16
million dollars with the stock 200 000
shares we just bought all those shares
back
uh under sixty dollars uh from a
previous acquisition so we used two
hundred thousand years in one
acquisition we bought them back we you
shoot them at 60 we bought them back
under 60. and then we turned around and
issued them at 80. uh when you're doing
those types of things it's very
accretive to the free cash flow for for
existing shareholders uh and I think you
know like I said financial advisors you
know grow grow and you know Equity was
cheap because you didn't have to pay it
back well actually your Equity is the
most expensive thing you can you can
issue if you're if you're free cash flow
yield if you're buying stuff at a at a
at a you know lower yield then you're
yielding on your own current assets
You're basically trading some of your
own assets to to acquire new ones and
that didn't once I figured all that out
just didn't make any sense and uh I I
think it's a you know it's a common
mistake out there uh in growth companies
that you must grow and you must grow and
you must grow and you know we've come to
the point where yes we must grow but we
must grow right uh we will pass on
transactions if they don't make sense uh
if the math doesn't work if we don't
feel confident that uh it'll add to our
free cash flow per share we'll we'll
we'll walk or pass on a transaction or
an acquisition uh we're building new
stuff but on our new stuff we demand
cash on cash returns of 25 to 33 percent
uh we will use leverage returns I mean
if I'm using Bank financing but I own
the real estate to me that interest
expense is just rent right and and my
rent goes down because every time I make
a principal payment my interest expense
decreases whereas average you know
company out there restaurants change
whatever they're leasing everything and
so their rents keep continue to go up
right two percent three percent every
year I tend to get five year fixed rates
or my my rents could go up you know five
years uh because my interest expense
could be could go up uh but right now
we're locked through about 2026 on most
of our financing we will be looking
uh in in 20 middle of 24 through the
middle of 25 on you know what we're
going to do on a refinance of that real
estate if the interest rates are low
enough we can we can pull cash out but
something that you know your landlord
doesn't give you any of your money back
or lets you borrow any of the money back
uh to for future growth so I think our
real estate has become an incredible
asset for the company in that regard as
well
when you start thinking about m a versus
building some of these facilities what
is that really is it just come down to
Pure financials or are there certain
things that you also uh Incorporated
that decision making
no I mean it's it's basically fifth
grade math you know everything goes on I
know like I said get back to pre cash
flow uh the issue is I can't guarantee a
growth rate of 10 to 15 percent with
Acquisitions alone because I can't tell
you when I'm going to get licensing
approvals when someone's going to be
willing to sell to me at a price that
I'm willing to pay and so we look for
ways to grow organically through the
building of the new Bombshells
restaurants maybe a new club here or
there of course now the casino
properties that we're doing uh in
Central City uh Colorado and so we we
want to have the organic growth combined
with the acquisition growth so that we
can steadily and consistently grow our
free cash flow per share at a 10 to 15
clip uh when we were doing it 75 million
dollars uh in in sales
10 to 15 growth was not that hard but in
15 million you know 15 million in free
cash flow but now that our free cash
flow is you know getting into 60 million
range now you're starting to have to buy
a considerable amount of of new new
ebitda to convert down into that free
cash flow and keep that growth rate
going where we're getting to 80 million
100 million 125 million in in uh in free
cash flow so
especially to do it just through
acquisition yeah so there's more details
here that I think uh people who are
unfamiliar with some of these uh
decisions they're not quite aware of so
for example you guys have Bombshells uh
which is in Texas I believe
um and for uh the kind of layman
description it would be like a Hooters
but more military-themed
um and it's a chain uh restaurant now
when you look at that uh location you
can go and you can build a you know a
27th or whatever it is location of 28th
29th the 30th location you're basically
taking an existing brand that you know
Works you've got a system in place and
you're essentially creating just another
location an extension of that versus if
you were to go in and try to build a
brand new brand a brand new location a
Brand New Concept in some City somewhere
and start from scratch it would seem
like the bombshell is kind of just
another location would uh uh be the
easier decision right because you kind
of have a lot of supporting figured out
but is it lower return profile versus
building a brand new nightclub for
example and A New Concept new brand in a
new city like how do you think about
risk and reward when it comes to where
you're going to go build something new
sure so with the clubs I obviously have
a moat right uh no one's going to come
compete with me anytime with Bombshells
you know you've got other brands out
there that can come and build and
compete and so your your longevity is
not guaranteed as as long as the as the
nightclubs are so we prefer the adult
nightclubs when we can do them but also
the Bombshells are not inexpensive to
build so to build a quality competitor
has to be willing to spend this you know
a similar amount of money uh and they
have to be willing to come in and try to
directly compete with us as well
uh so you you know there's a little bit
of a moat there uh plus with the
Bombshells we're able to get Bank
financing we buy the real estate uh
we're able to get Bank financing on it
so our out front cost about 25 cost the
restaurant so if a unit is six million
dollars to build uh you know we only
have to come up with a million five in
cash uh typically we cash on cash return
that anywhere from 14 months to 38
months so our cash on cash returns meet
our criteria of 25 to 33 sometimes it's
a hundred percent uh we've had units uh
I've also had units where we built
everything out in Cashland gone to the
bank got a appraisal on the property and
we pulled four 400 000 more out of the
bank loan than we spent to buy the land
and build the entire thing so we're 400
000 cash on cash up day one every dollar
we make out of the restaurant is just
you know infinite return right uh and so
that's one of the nice things I think
about Bombshells uh we're going through
a tougher time because we have really
hard cops we were one of the few places
that opened immediately uh we had all of
our stores reopened by about May 15th
after closing March 1st so we weren't
closed for very long with Bombshells we
wanted a few things open uh our sales
were absolutely fantastic for about two
or three years so we're running against
incredible comps uh against you know 100
degree heat outside in Texas right now
we're a patio an outdoor patio is a
major portion of our late night business
where we bring in DJs and turn our patio
basically into a nightclub uh in the
evenings and so that business is
Sovereign that's all you know 40 plus
margin business it's all appetizers and
alcohol
uh but you know still in the last
quarter we made 1.7 million dollars
according for that we made 1.9 million
dollars uh we're already cashed on cash
over 100 Roi on our cash and cash
Investments and all the Bombshells
Concepts over 10 years old and and uh
we're building in another Houston right
now we're building in uh in a Dallas
area we're building in Lubbock Texas uh
we're building uh two locations in
Denver now so we'll be expanding into
Colorado
uh as well as a Bombshells Sports casino
that we're going to be building up in
Central City uh with a full Bombshells
restaurant in it so a lot of exciting
stuff for that concept uh and like I
said the the ROI on it is great it's
just been very difficult this last 12
months or so but the comps will
eventually we're going to hit the lower
comps and and things will get back to
normal and we should run 18 to 22
margins our margins are a little
squeezed right now uh we've been a
little slower in bringing down our costs
uh to the level because we kind of
hoping the business would would rebound
uh if it doesn't we'll adjust
accordingly as we as we're doing at this
current time and uh and and bring
everything back in line our patio
business would come back as soon as the
weather breaks and uh we'll be back to
normal
and then when you start thinking about
regulation obviously when you're on a
restaurant you got the liquor license
and things there when you think of the
uh nightclubs
um and the establishments you you've got
a bunch of regulations you got to deal
with uh and then you start talking about
casinos there's all the gambling and and
uh seems like the United States is
becoming more receptive and synthetic to
uh to gambling but how do you navigate
not only just regulation in general you
actually have three different types of
Regulation that you're having to deal
with here right and it's highly complex
but you also got to run a business you
got to keep margin you got to keep
growing like like this is not as simple
of a business I think as people may
think on the surface and so talk a
little bit about the regulation what you
guys have done there biggest fortunes
aren't made on Wall Street they used to
be made there but now they're being made
in private markets consider Mike Walsh
he put five thousand dollars into Uber
he's just a regular dude turned it over
24 million dollars such opportunities
were once held behind closed doors
reserved for those who had connections
or vast fortunes but not anymore start
engine is now going to tear down that
glass ceiling and make startup
Investments possible for you and me the
company is led by Howard marks the
co-founder of gaming giant Activision
and they got 1.7 million users that have
put in over 1.2 billion dollars of
transactions on the platform but the
best part is the platform's not even
backed by traditional Venture
capitalists it's backed basically by the
community they've raised over 75 million
dollars in crowdsource funding to date
go check them out at startengine.com you
can open up a start engine account today
and you can explore live investing
opportunities with starting investing
amounts as little as a hundred dollars
startengine.com go check them out today
why don't you corporatize everything and
you have processes right we have
in-house legal counsel with you know
three paralegals that work for a company
full time they probably have nine
outside law firms that we deal with on a
on a you know weekly monthly basis uh so
you use a lot of lawyers obviously uh
but you create a lot of systems uh we
try to uh use technology to the best of
our advantage to track and keep track
you know uh you have an Erp system now
in our accounting office that you can
run financials and get data in seconds
uh versus the old spreadsheet days where
you know took week to get you know if I
wanted to know
something that take me a week to find
out now I can get it in seconds uh
inventory control systems uh you know I
can tell you I can go push a button and
tell you how many bottles of any type of
vodka you want to know any certain
whiskey you wonder how many did we how
many did we buy in the last month last
week last 12 months
uh and so that data gives us uh
unbelievable control and power over uh
negotiations with vendors for example
keeping our costs down National buying
power uh you know with with whether it's
Coca-Cola or it's Pepsi whether it's uh
you know Southern Southern Wine and
Spirits or Republic or uh you know the
different brands we can go to different
brands and say you know you want we'll
we we sell this amount of this brand in
x amount of your brand what could we do
you know what would it be worth if we
can get your brand from 1 000 cases to 3
000 cases uh and and you know here's how
we would do it through our VIP uh VIP
menus uh those types of things you know
what kind of marketing sport could you
give us uh you know there's there's laws
that don't allow them to actually give
us money but uh but there are ways for
them to help us sell their product and
if they're helping us sell their product
it makes our jobs or makes our jobs
easier yeah that makes a lot of sense
and then when we think of um kind of
other parts of the business technology
is a huge piece you're here talking
about kind of inventory management and
really having kind of uh granular
understanding of what you guys have
ordered what you could order what uh
various sales are but you've also built
out a certain uh number of other
products or services so things like you
essentially have an only fans competitor
to some degree to allow the entertainers
to have direct connections with uh kind
of their fans or Their audience talk a
little bit about the technology uh
initiatives that you guys have underway
yeah well that one's being developed
right now uh we're trying to get a
product that we can actually live launch
and really put some money in influencers
behind uh we do have some feature
entertainers we're starting to work with
to start to load some content on the
site uh we'll probably start buying and
directing traffic to that site very very
soon uh the idea is that not only you
know if you're on a convention in Denver
for example and you meet uh uh you know
Susie at the at the club and then you go
back home to Idaho and you want to stay
in touch with her now you can follow her
on her Fan's website at
admireme.com and keep in touch and then
the next time you're in Denver you can
you can you can come by the club and see
her again uh you know and so it also
helps our entertainers build not only
their uh
in club presence but I hope some build a
business online as well to give them
additional sources of income and Revenue
yeah that makes sense and then how do
you think about
um how much of that is uh going back to
kind of serving the Entertainer and
trying to provide a place where they
want to continue to work and come to the
various clubs Etc versus it's a revenue
optimization and it's hey how do we get
money flowing through this and get
transaction volume so that we then can
uh take a fee and drive real Revenue all
right I I think the reality of it is
it's it all feeds it's all feeds to each
other right I mean one doesn't work
without the other uh and so uh I always
have a a saying with everyone if you
want if you want more pie we don't take
somebody else's piece we make the pie
bigger uh and I think admire me as part
of making that pie bigger right we don't
need to we don't the girls don't need to
take our money we don't need to take
their money we just need to make the pie
bigger so that everybody is getting
additional you know additional money
that way yeah that makes sense
um private jets uh I know that you are a
pilot it's something that you for a long
time have been very passionate about
talk about uh one why is it so valuable
for you guys to use the private chats
and kind of get from location to
location how how do you think about
saving time and money from that
standpoint well I mean you know I could
leave my house right now and be in
Denver in two hours and 40 minutes uh I
can be in New York and
probably 2 hours and 55 minutes I can be
in Miami in probably two hours and five
minutes uh with all the locations we
have uh and and the real thing is I can
travel at any time day or night right if
I want to go stay at the club till three
o'clock in the morning and then jump in
the plane and be home and be at a
meeting at seven o'clock or eight
o'clock in the morning when I get home
uh I'm able to to make those types of
things happen uh if we get a call uh you
know oh hey there's a club for sale in
Milwaukee
you know by the time I would
book a fly get to the airport ahead of
time check my bags get my bags uncheck
my bags It's Paper hotel rooms all that
type of stuff because I gotta can't get
a flight back home that same night uh
you know it's just it's just a
convenience and a quality of life thing
as well as you know we're fast right we
need to react or move something fast we
we can do so uh uh you know the overall
cost when you look at the tax benefits
of of corporate aircraft and some of the
other things that hey I mean I'm not
gonna act like it's cheaper to fly in a
private jet than it is commercial but
it's competitive uh especially the
smaller plane and we have a you have a
vision jet a serious Vision jet which
you know Phil Burns about 70 gallons an
hour does 300 miles an hour so if you do
the price you know price per hour that's
a dollar something an hour or a dollar
something a mile which you know it's not
it's not crazy uh but it allows us to
get you know 27 locations in Texas uh it
allows us to get to if we need to get to
Odessa Texas I can be in Odessa Texas in
an hour or so I can be in you know if I
have to be in El Paso they have to be in
Austin Dallas you know I can be in any
other cities very very quickly
and then part of what I think is the
most shocking is you're flying the plane
yourself like you don't have a pilot
normally flying you usually it's you
flying usually I mean I've had I I I
only started flying about 13 years ago I
bought my first plane in 1991. uh
so I flew in the back for a long long
time uh
but uh you know I have learned to fly uh
about 13 years ago uh discovered the
freedom of it now I don't have to worry
about pilot I don't have to worry about
you know it was three o'clock in the
morning has he been sleeping has he been
drinking can I get out of here I need to
be somewhere uh and so that freedom uh
to me is is is invaluable uh yeah I
gotta go to Flight Training every year
Dwight you know for well two times a
year because I got two different we fly
two different types of aircraft I have
two different type ratings uh so I have
to go to Flight Training for those I
have to you know stay current I have to
fly a certain amount but I mean we I
probably fly 200 hours a year uh on
average right now so it's it's not it's
not really an issue uh to me it's you
know everybody says well gosh you're
gonna go you know you're gonna go fly as
soon as I said you're gonna drive an
hour and 15 minutes home if you live in
New York City you know if you work in
New York City you live outside the city
you can drive an hour 15 minutes home at
four o'clock in the morning I'm gonna
get in a plane and fly for an hour 45
minutes who cares you know it's not it's
just my my car right I mean that's the
way I look at it yeah
um there's a a Forbes interview that you
gave a couple years ago and in it you
talk about loneliness and uh uh kind of
this idea that uh many of the people who
come into uh the nightclubs Etc uh they
don't have a lot of friends they they're
coming in for something that isn't you
know material possessions talk a little
bit about what you've seen there and
maybe the contribution of the pandemic
and people being locked at home and now
trying to come back out and you know
kind of reintegrate as a society
yeah I mean I try to say you know
everybody thinks that you're in the sex
business or I mean the sex appeal is
definitely part of our business but the
reality is we sell human interaction
uh I mean if you look at the if you look
at the numbers today the birthing rate's
down right the uh the number of men
under the age of 30 that you know aren't
sexually active uh you know don't want
to get married don't want girlfriends
don't want you know so where did they
what what is their release how do they
how do they create that human
interaction uh and they don't know how
they spend so much time on computer
screens they don't really have the
social skills the beauty of going to a
strip club is the girls have all the
social skills that you need as I would
say you know to a customer so a guy can
come in I mean we've done a couple of
big parties uh when we were launching an
nft project and you know in Miami we had
a bunch of guys come in uh for the nfts
and uh you know they're very excited
about crypto and the nfts because crypto
is very big in Miami and they come into
the club and they'll be like
you know wow I didn't know it was like
this this isn't what I expected he goes
how come the girls are so friendly you
know am I why do the girls like me so
much I was like well you know it's it's
it's that's their job right that's what
they do uh he goes yeah but it seems you
know they're very sincere I said well
because they genuinely want you to have
a good time they're not you know they
yes they want to make money but they
also they're having fun this is a fun
job for them right I mean do they want
to go sit in an office or in a cubicle
or do they want to you know come drink
and hang out with guys and have a good
time and and and make money uh so I said
it's a you know it's a win-win for
everybody in that regard uh and I think
it helps you know it's amazing how many
guys are actually afraid to talk to a
female it's like guys just go talk to
her I mean well she's pretty awesome
we'll go talk to her she's too pretty
for me to talk to him like there's no
such thing as someone being too pretty
she's over there thinking you that she's
not pretty because if you're not you're
not you're not paying attention or you
don't like her now she thinks
something's wrong with her you know
she's getting a complex so you can it's
you go talk to her and you know it works
out uh it works out pretty well for
everybody I think in the end so
when you start to think about
um kind of the business it's gotten much
bigger over the last couple of years
where do you envision this going kind of
what is the plan or kind of your future
goals in terms of growing the business
for my revenue and profitability
standpoint but also uh expansion is it
going into more of the gaming stuff is
it just more restaurants and nightclubs
how do you think about this
I mean everything complements basically
the business we're in is is the alcohol
sales business right we're in the we're
in the nightclub bar business we sell we
sell our clock Beverages and that's
where we make the majority of our money
probably uh
definitely margin wise uh and I think
that if you look everything we've done
the casinos the the Bombshells
everything kind of builds around that
core
business of using some type of
entertainment to then you know to to
basically sell alcohol or sell a fun
time right it's a it's a it's a good
time out it's a fun part uh you know I
used to joke I said man this is the
greatest job in the world I get paid
throw a party seven days a week
uh
you know where where can you find a job
like that uh unfortunately my job's
evolved and now I actually have a
corporate job so I get paid for to make
sure other people throw the party seven
days a week uh but yet I can go join the
party anytime I want and I think that's
kind of the beauty of our Industries
anybody can come in and and join the
party uh uh you know we try to treat
everyone that that comes to our business
as a guest not a customer uh as a person
not a number uh and whether you spend
fifty dollars or fifty thousand dollars
uh we want to make sure you have a good
time and that you you know your whatever
level of of
uh you know customer or guest level you
want to be that that you're able to able
to enjoy that
talk about being a public company CEO
you've been doing it for now two decades
uh maybe a little bit more than two
decades
um
how has it changed over the years like
obviously the internet and social media
like there's been a lot of change in
society but as a public company CEO what
are some of the things that have stayed
constant and what are some of the
biggest changes that you've had to
navigate
I mean audited financials uh are
obviously very different than you know a
a private company uh after
sarbanes-oxley was passed the the amount
of Regulation I mean it takes four
people to get a check cut in our company
uh you know I used to go grab the
checkbook and write checks
with a pen myself right I mean you can't
even get a check there are no checks the
computer prints them and until there's
four approvals the computer won't print
them so there's not even a check to
write any
uh so that's that's been uh that that's
that's been an amazing thing for me to
to get used to as a as the CEO uh
uh you know you just the the checks and
balances but at the same time I think
it's it's it's fantastic because
everything's documented everything's
followed I mean uh video cameras
everything's recorded everything's set
so uh you know they're all the all that
he said she said all the you know the
what if it's all documented these days
uh and so it's very easy to defend any
position that we have or any position we
take
uh and so I really like that side of it
uh it's become a business I mean I
remember when I first started out the
business I mean shoot I was probably
legally drunk I didn't drive I lived at
the club so I didn't have to drive so
without that help uh but I mean I
probably drank every
other day three four five times a week
and now our management team's not
allowed to drink at all uh you know
waitresses would would get drunk and
then we'd have to like silver them up
get him rides home you know our wait
staff doesn't drink anymore uh it's
become very very corporate in in that
regard uh which I think like I said has
pluses and minuses to the to the overall
deal but uh it's it's made it a I think
a
a safer funner environment for everyone
involved
and then you employ tons of young people
and if you were to go on uh Twitter or
you know go read news articles they'll
tell you about how young people don't
work hard or young people are
complaining about this or that or
they're too woke or they're too ESG
focused or you know name your critique
of young people what are the pluses and
minuses of having so many young people
work for you like there's pros and cons
what do you see those being
well I think the beauty of most of the
young people that work for us is they
come to us with a necessity to work for
some reason right whether they're a
single parent whether they're uh you
know there's something in their life
that has brought them to our industry
and I think our industry empowers them
to not only recover
from whatever brought them there in the
first place but to allow them to excel
uh and to create a much better life for
themselves and for their families uh
and I I you know to me that's that's my
motivation you know people ask me all
the time why why do you why do you keep
doing this why do you know what's your
end goal uh you know when are you gonna
retire what's your retirement plan
you've been doing this you know 30 I
started the 19 so I've really been in
the business 36 years it's like you know
I can't there's too many people that
count on me every single day uh you know
too many too many families too many uh
weather employees whether entertainers
uh it doesn't matter to me uh and our
guests I mean our guests uh use use our
use our business uh as as their you know
that's their social experiences and we
have a lot of regulars that are you know
that love our clubs they love you know
love the entertainers they love the
management teams and the employees uh at
the clubs and they kind of become you
know part of the family uh and so to me
that's that's the that's the motivation
in the drive that keeps me uh keeps me
working every day
my last question for you is uh today the
company is somewhere 600 650 uh million
dollar market cap uh the billion dollar
uh numbers out there I've seen you tweet
about building a billion dollar strip
club Empire the whole thing
um what is the importance of that number
and is there you know something that you
think kind of that billion dollar Mark
unlocks other than just the fact that
you can say that you did it
uh you know I think I think it's gonna
add uh a validation to our company uh I
think some people still look at us as a
strip club company uh oh they're just in
a strip club business oh they're just
you know they're just strip club guys or
they're just strippers I think with a
billion dollar market cap Corporate
America has to go
wow and pay attention uh we got very
close uh I think we got the 900 and some
million uh so we got very close uh this
past January uh I I think we're
undervalued right now uh and I think
that we'll start seeing the the
realization of the investment we're
making uh as we move into 2024 and
hopefully we'll get that Mark uh I think
it's just a number you know my old
number used to be 30 million dollars I
need my stock to be worth 30 million
dollars I want a net worth of 30 million
dollars well I hit that 2008 and I said
now what okay wait and that's just a
number let's go back to work you know uh
if it's actually a you know a billion
dollar Mark caps probably a meaningless
number
and the overall deal but it's also like
I said it's a I think it's a validation
point for our our staff our employees
for myself uh you know that hey we've
actually created you know a billion
dollar market cap company I mean you
know if it was 30 years ago we'd
probably be happy at 10 million right
that'd be a big that'd be a big number
but today you got to get that b out
there uh and so I you know that's that's
kind of the the goal of it I call it
Monopoly money you know you play the
Monopoly and you know the money stacks
up into your side of the board it looks
good but you can't really buy anything
with it you can't do anything with it
but so I think that's kind of the I
think that's kind of what it's about uh
and like I said you know it does have a
nice ring right a billion dollars so uh
I always laugh you know when you think
back because I don't know the old Austin
Powers movie where uh Dr Evil gets out
and he goes we want a million dollars
and the guy goes no no no that's not a
billion dollar bill oh billion dollars
you know so uh you know I think kind of
you know just be fun right I mean the
reality of is it's not going to change
anything uh other than probably the
stock price uh will have to be up
considerably which will make a lot of
people very very happy especially uh
Adam Wyden uh of ADW capital is our
largest shareholder uh you know he's I
have to admit he's been with us for
butter stock and coveted stayed with us
other other people sold uh when stock
hit 90s he stayed with us he's he's
backed us he supports us uh and uh you
know I can't uh can't thank him enough
for uh
for believing in us you know and I think
that uh you know we're gonna we're gonna
pay him dividends when the stock gets
that billion dollar he'll he'll get his
validation too for the people that give
him helper for owning part of the strip
club company
Eric where can we send people to find
you on the internet if people want to
follow along as you continue to build
the company sure I'm on Twitter at
Rick's r-i-c-k-s-c-o uh that's that's my
Twitter handle I'm on Twitter probably
every single day I I try to post uh
especially now Elon wants to pay me you
know if I can get five million
impressions so I've been spending more
time on uh on Twitter than I have and in
the past few months but I actually
enjoyed Twitter a lot it's it's a fun
it's fun fun to hang out well I'm sorry
X now I better better correct myself
there uh but uh you know I enjoy posting
I enjoy the the back and forth and what
I really love the most is you know I was
an operations guy from 19 until I don't
know probably 2010 2012. uh and so I was
daily contact right with it with the
guest with the employees and I think you
know the platform X gives me the
opportunity to get that feedback to get
that one-on-one whether it's direct
messaging or whether you know we're
talking in public forums but it allows
me to uh you know to to basically get a
taste of that uh that direct contact
again and really hear from people uh
whether it's problems uh whether it's
praise you know it doesn't really matter
whether we're just as they call it
posting it doesn't matter you know it's
it's just a way to communicate and uh
and really get a pulse of uh of our
industry of the people that uh that
follow us of our investors potential
investors and really get our story to
the masses uh and it's you know
inexpensive what eight bucks a month
right
so they used to be free but that makes
sense to me well listen Eric thank you
so much for taking the time to do this
we'll definitely do it again in the
future okay appreciate you